más sanciones a los oligarcas rusos
españa detuvo el yate ley de anastasia
valorado en más de 7 millones de dólares
y que es propiedad de alexandr mijéyev
director de un grupo fabricante de armas
ruso esto es parte de la respuesta
también común europea consecuencia de
las sanciones que hemos acordado los
países miembros para oficiar la economía
de rusia y que eso pueda conllevar
también que se rebaje la agresión hacia
el pueblo ucraniano el lunes otra
embarcación avaluada en 140 millones de
dólares había sido inmovilizada en
barcelona- bajo sospecha de pertenecer
al oligarca serguéi chémezov un ex
oficial de la calle y cercano a vladimir
putin entretanto eeuu impuso este martes
más castigos a 11 militares rusos
responsables de la represión a las
manifestaciones contra la guerra en
ucrania que han tenido lugar en moscú
canadá que prometió más ayuda militar
financiera y humanitaria ucrania también
anunció sanciones a funcionarios rusos
estas sanciones están en línea con
nuestro socio de la unión europea y
elevan el número total de personas y
entidades sancionadas por canadá a casi
500 desde que rusia invadió ucrania el
24 de febrero
occidente ha congelado los activos y ha
aislado a rusia de la economía global
desde el inicio de la invasión a ucrania
el 24 de febrero rusia en respuesta puso
al presidente joe biden primer ministro
justin trudeau ya una decena de
funcionarios estadounidenses entre ellos
el secretario de estado antonio blink en
el de defensa lloyd austin en una lista
de bloqueo que les prohíbe ingresar a
rusia una medida simbólica ya que es
poco probable que los funcionarios
viajen a moscú en el corto plazo